想像一下一邊是拿著書本引用麻將理論的教授
說斷線交易沒有價值
另一邊是單月交易量突破800億的當衝高手
直言學術理論管不了市場
這兩派在台股上隔空交火火化自射
網友們紛紛做好板凳準備看好戲
今天我們就來拆解這場史詩集的論戰
看看短線操作長期持有哪一種最適合你
真意核心短線交易到底是不是複合賽局
事情的起點是周冠南教授在臉書發文
強調短期交易在扣除交易稅與手續費後
整體更接近複合賽局
他用麻將理論比喻
如果沒有莊家抽投
輸贏戶底總和為零
一旦加入抽成
就算有人技術再好
整體玩家仍會被系統性成本慢慢侵蝕
教授借此提醒多数散户
频繁短线交易往往不是在和市场拼技巧
而是在和成本硬碰硬
这个观点迅速引发市场讨论
也点燃了另一派实战高手的反击
两种世界观的正面交锋
随着讨论延烧
这场争论逐渐升级为学术派与实战派的正面交锋
学术派强调长期持有与指数投资
认为多数投资人不具备资讯
速度与心理优势与其在短线中反复试错不如把时间交给优质企業與整體市場讓富利慢慢發揮效果相對來說實戰派則認為市場並非完全有效
只要有方法有紀律
短線交易本身就是一種專業技能
他們不否認成本存在
但強調重點不在能不能短線
而在你是不是那個能夠長期活下來的人
這也讓討論焦點從單純的理論對錯
轉為對投資人自身條件的解釋
網友觀點三派系
這場論戰在網路上掀起了熱烈討論
大家的觀點大致可以分成三種
第一種是天賦派
他們認為如果你有時間、經驗和判斷力
短線操作是可行的
但對大多數普通投資人來說
盲目嘗試短線交易往往徒勞無功
容易被市場節奏壓垮
第二種務實派比較保守
認為大部分人沒有辦法全天候冰盤
也不熟悉複雜的公式
因此長期持有或投資指數
才是最穩健的累積財務方式
這種策略不追求短期暴力
而是靠時間慢慢增值
第三種則是策略混合派
他們覺得兩種方法可以互補
核心部分長期持有
穩健累積財富
衛星部分則靈活運用短線操作
抓住市場波動帶來的機會
另外也要注意台灣加權指數的高度集中
台積電約佔整個指數的60%
這意味著指數投資的分散效果並不理想在考慮策略時理解指數投資與個股投資的差異對風險控管相當重要
投資路線大不同
0050還是台積電
拿0050跟台積電來說
其實能很直觀看出投資路徑的差異
對沒有時間研究個股的人來說
0050就像自動過濾器
跳出長期表現穩健的龍頭股
長期持有就比較省心
反過來說 15 年前直接買台積電一路持有
那就是典型的主動投資
需要研究公司基本面也得承擔判斷的風險
但好處是能享受企業成長帶來的紅利和股價增值
兩者都可能受益於台積電的長期成長
但資金分佈 風險成熟度和心理壓力則完全不同
要注意 指數投資過去10年的好表現
很大程度是靠多投行情加持
遇到极端空投
結果可能就差很多
建議怎麼投資才對你胃口
對多數人來說
長期持有人是最現實也最容易執行的核心策略
把資金放在大型ETF或具代表性的全職股上
不必每天盯盤
也不用試圖抓住每一次波動
重點在於讓時間與市場的長期成長替你工作
這種做法的優勢不在於短期報酬有多亮眼
而是在於心理壓力低 犯錯機率小
能夠真正陪你走過多頭與空頭
至於短線操作它從來不是不能碰而是不是人人都適合短線交易賺的是市場的波動而不是企業的未來真正的難度不在於進場
而在於能否嚴格執行停損
控制部位並長期維持紀律
這條路適合那些有時間
有經驗
也清楚知道自己在承擔什麼風險的人
而不是一時被績效吸引
臨時起義的嘗試
也因此越來越多投資人
選擇折中的方式
以長期持有作為核心
確保資產能穩定累積
再搭配一部分資金
進行短線或撥斷操作
為整體報酬創造額外彈性
在這種配置之下
核心部位不需要頻繁調整
負責活得久
而衛星操作則必須嚴守紀律
捨停損負責多賺一點
這樣的策略不追求極端績效
以不把自己推到高壓狀態
而是在风险可控的前提之下
让投资变成一件能够长期执行
而且不会把生活搞乱的事情
结论你会怎么选
这场论战没有标准答案
因为市场从来不缺方法
缺的是适合自己也能够长期执行的策略
与其选边站不如先想清楚
你的时间风险承受度与个性
究竟适合哪一种投资方式
如果你喜欢我们今天的内容
记得加入我们的LINE社群
里面有很多丰富的小秘密
等着跟你分享哦